[Musique]
bonsoir les bras tendus de salut
derrière les murs noirs la milice est
synonyme dans les canaux l'occupation de
terreur et d'horreur mais peut-être pour
commencer faut-il rappeler en trois mots
qu'est ce que c'était la milice
la milice sont vraiment c'est la milice
française c'est donc la milice de l'état
français créé par l'état français dont
kate à vichy soit le 30 janvier 1943
c'est une c'est donc une milice un
mouvement politique une milice de mise
en réserve par l'état français qui
s'était donné au départ une double
mission d'abord animé la vie politique
de l'état français et d'autre part
concourir au maintien de l'homme et
courseulles elle va être progressivement
armés on va suivre tout au long de cette
émission l'histoire de cette milice en
évolution mais d'abord aujourd'hui quand
un historien veut travailler sur
l'histoire de la milice quelle source il
assure qu'elle archives il peut
travailler et bien dispose de sources
fiables
il dispose des dossiers d'instruction
très bien fait de procès en particulier
du procès de joseph darnand dont s'est
largement inspiré un livre des gens
siens l'histoire de la milice par
jacques perrier de bayac publiait donc
chez fayard en 1969 il dispose également
de dossiers d'instruction relativement
bien fait de cour de justice lorsque les
miliciens ont été jugés donc à la
libération il dispose encore d'une très
vaste en tête de gendarmerie du
printemps 1945 de en gros ce qui s'est
passé dans la france profonde dans l'été
1944 il dispose encore d' enquêtes
départementales fait par un certain
nombre d'historiens de l'institut
d'histoire du temps présent bref en tant
qu'historien nous nous estimons
suffisamment armé pour parler et de la
milice et des miliciens puisque vous
êtes armé on va maintenant plongé dans
l'histoire de la miss retour à 1940 aux
origines
[Musique]
je me suis adressée 7,6 à l'adversaire
vous lui demandez il est très tard
effectué avec moi entre-temps ça après
la lutte est un des moyens de mettre un
terme aux hostilités
[Musique]
au lendemain de la débâcle le chef de
l'état français se fixe comme premier
objectif le redressement moral et
intellectuel du pays
à défaut de parti unique pétain compte
sur les anciens combattants pour servir
d'encadrement rallier au prestigieux
vainqueur de verdun les poilus de 14-18
apparaissent en effet au nouveau régime
comme d'excellents propagandistes de la
révolution nationale
[Musique]
dès le 29 août 1940 pétain créé la
légion du combattant
ils seront bientôt des centaines de
milliers à répondre maréchal nous voilà
à montoir en octobre 40 pétain s'engage
dans la politique de la collaboration
avec l'occupant
la légion des combattants devient un
véritable mouvement de masse un journal
est lancé les jeunes ont une émission
quotidienne à la radio distance la bonne
parole disciplinés les troupes de la
légion comme unis lors de vastes
rassemblements dans l'amour du chef
[Musique]
enterré grande tournée légionnaires
grande journée française qui restera
dans les annales de toulouse comme le
témoignage de son attachement à la
révolte nationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à paris en zone occupée les fascistes
pur et dur impatient d'en découdre prône
la collaboration armée et crée la légion
des volontaires français contre le
bolchevisme la lvf
un grand meeting de lancement est
organisée au vélodrome d'hiver le 18
juillet à 41
la belle unanimité de façade masquer des
rivalités d'apprentis fureur
tant mieux si la france resté puissances
européennes et mondiales si la france
veut rester 10 de la rue ils font
quelque chose de bien avec elle pour le
mot cheville il y a pas été vendu
malgré les images de propagande les
volontaires pour le front de l'est sont
rares
dans quelques jours ces jeunes femmes
seront aux côtés de ceux qui luttent là
bas afin de protéger l'europe et la
france des dangers bolcheviks
en zone sud pour le 1er anniversaire de
la création de la légion des combattants
vichy organise un grand spectacle
médiatique retransmis de ville en ville
par la radio
avec mon gouvernement est pour lui
arracher son grand jour
et c'est un
son village tunis est au serment
prononcé par le chef est retransmis de
10,6 par radio
sacré effort ça n'a pas nui à la famille
au travail et
je m'engage annecy dit que l'amitié de
notre haine vis-à-vis de mes camarades
tu es de guerre
à rester fidèle à la mémoire de ce
marché et au champ d'honneur
j'accepte qu'il revend la discipline de
la légion tout ce qui me sera comment
des revues de saintes idéal
mais de la légion fête de l'unité
française en étendant le titre de la
légion le maréchal a signifié son
intention de s'appuyer sur les effectifs
sans cesse plus de tous ceux qui veulent
secondes et son action en confirmant
leur adhésion à la politique du maréchal
les légionnaires ont signifié que le
grand soldat incarnait alors ce que la
france elle même ces masses au fond sont
désormais l'instrument grâce au foehn et
l'on fera une doctrine qui selon le mot
de monsieur valentin directeur général
de la légion mais là ce avait des
expériences moderne et les traditions du
génie prophète a sonné par des steaks
les humanistes
les plus activistes des légionnaires
estime que ce rassemblement de père de
famille ne sera jamais un mouvement
politique efficace
c'est alors que joseph darnand le chef
de la légende des alpes-maritimes créé
le service d'ordre légionnaire le sol
darnand veut regrouper les éléments les
plus combatifs afin de former un
groupement paramilitaires
très anti républicain très anti
communiste très antisémite les militants
du sol se veulent une avant garde de la
révolution nationale
des arènes de cimiez 2000 membres du
service d'ordre légionnaire réunis
autour de françois valentin prononcé
après avoir entendu les porte-paroles de
darnand le serment qui le fera a selon
la formule légionnaires les chevaliers
des temps modernes
sortie du puits au fond de son peuple
tu as l'air de cacher vous aurez
l'honneur de servir
de servir chaque jour obstinément à la
tâche quotidienne du redressement
français se servir dans les phares
turbie glorieuse que l'avenir est le
chef pourront vous réservez ce n'est
peut-être votre sens votre vie avec pour
seule récompense la joie d'avoir servi à
jouer
je m'engage sur l'honneur à servir la
france c'est le maréchal pétain chef de
religion
a consacré de mes poches à faire
triompher la révolution nationale et
sociale
dans les os de mes chefs et la
discipline librement acceptées du
vaisseau elle est stone elle
[Musique]
de la france au service du maréchal de
forces nouvelles et ferait aujourd'hui
prête à lutter et à servir et à souffrir
la renaissance entre
[Musique]
le 8 novembre 42 les alliés tentent un
département en afrique du nord
c'est l'opération torch pétain ordonne à
l'armée d'afrique de kiné elle
n'empêchera pas les américains de
débarquer à alger
[Musique]
hitler trois jours plus tard donne
l'ordre à ses troupes de franchir la
ligne de démarcation
il y a plus de zone prétendument libre
il n'ya plus d'empyr l'armée d'armistice
disparaît sans gloire la fiction d'un
est un français s'envole à toulon le 27
novembre la flotte française se saborde
ces événements précipitent les
changements à vichy
[Musique]
on
le 19 décembre 1942 le führer exige de
laval la création d'une force de police
qui devra collaborer avec les allemands
au maintien de l'ordre en france
où trouver les troupes sinon parmi les
légionnaires de darnand
lors de la milice est venu
on voit sur ces images des défauts assez
consommer rabeschi finalement le sol
recruter tant que ça at&t ses effectifs
des vies c'est à dire non pas le chiffre
exact on peut
sont probablement entre dix et douze
mille membres plus ou moins actifs
disons en zone sud wii exclusivement au
dessus mais on a oublié de préciser que
les allemands interdisait pour le moment
donc tout en devenant donc en zone
occupée interdisait à la fois les gens
des combattants et a fortiori donc le
service doivent légionnaires faut
signaler qu'un certain paul touvier
secrétaire du sol et series en
légionnaires en savoie dès janvier
quarante deux croiseurs réseau est le
personnage le personnage évidemment qui
émerge effet les centrales ces
personnages de joseph darnand qu'un peu
symbolique de ce recrutement du sol à ce
moment là et on va dire deux mots mais
auparavant je voudrais dire aussi qu'ils
prêtent serment
par rapport à un texte qui est très
précis qui s'appelle les 21 points du
service d'ordre légionnaire et qui
deviendra pratiquement inchangé les 21
points de la mitis coloration illogique
et l'inde se maintient point c'est
contre la lèpre juive pour la pureté
française je reviens à votre question
d'argent que le patron celui de joe joe
joseph celui qui a dans le fond l'idée
de créer ce service d'un légionnaire
celui qui va devenir le secrétaire
général de la mise celui qui va devenir
de secrétaire général au maintien de
l'ordre à ce moment là avec rang de
ministre à partir de 1944 joseph darnand
disons que ce n'est pas un fils
d'archevêque comme nous disons à peu
dans notre jargon d'historiens son
origine est modeste d'une famille
modeste cathodique c'est un ancien
combattant très valeureux 10 citations
réinsertion sociale plus ou moins bien
fait comme une partie de ses anciens
combattants c'est un héros de la guerre
de 14 18
tout à fait ensuite diane eager alors il
fait si dans toutes les ligues mais
beaucoup actions françaises
cadeau du roi il sera un petit bout tant
au parti populaire français le vpf de
jacques doriot et y sera aussi surtout
un des maillons les plus efficaces dans
le sud-est puisque
s'était installé près de nice pour la
cagoule donc ce comité secret d'action
révolutionnaire qui voulait par un coup
de faire basculer ou renverser la
république 30 cette émission c'est tout
à fait donc les bains voilà c'était un
c'était un instrument il est fait
prisonnier en 1940 après avoir animé un
corps francs il le sait va très
rapidement il devient pétainiste tout à
fait convaincu il est donc dans la
région des combattants il est ensuite
pratiquement le nombre le membre
fondateur avec 70 de ses amis donc du
service d'ordre légionnaire et il va
devenir patron de la milice et même le
journal je crois du sol niçois fin de
qui l'animent s'appelle la trique
et alors il ya à l'automne à l'automne
42 millions le département en afrique du
nord l'invasion de la zone sud ça va
changer la situation politique et laval
qui étaient opposés longtemps va à cette
idée va être amenée évidemment à créer
prenant à proprement parler une force de
nous cette fameuse mise qu'est ce qui
pousse la balle a créé au début 43 la
milice
pour une double raison la première c'est
que il est pressé par les uns par les
autres qui estime que la balle est trop
mou en particulier dans la répression
donc il veut montrer qu' il n'est en
place s'il trouve qu'il est trop mou de
collaborationniste parisien je sais les
collaborateurs se sont donc des
militants le plus souvent de l'extrême
droite d'ultra droite qui milite pour
une collaboration militaire tous azimuts
et qui sont
ces auditions ont créé de fait la légion
des volontaires français contre le
bolchevisme donc là en juillet 1940 hier
les représentants c'est doriot c'est
doriot
oui
doriot déat mais aussi toute une série
de journalistes par exemple ceux que
l'on retrouve à je suis partout et puis
toute une série de mouvements les
francis d un certain nombre de petits
bouts - qui sont créées qui vont se
rallier à la fois l'idée de la
collaboration militaire pour mériter
leur place dans l'europe fasciste de
myers et l'europe qui pensaient fasciste
plutôt plutôt qu'allemande donc voila ce
milieu parisien j'ai déjà mentionné
trouve que ce milieu parisien que laval
est un est un mot dernier donnant
dormeur bon on en voilà donc une
catégorie l'autre c'est à monsieur c'est
adolf hitler trouve que les français
ça n'a pas la collaboration
franco-allemande et que la france n'est
pas suffisamment fiable que d'autre part
l'afrique du nord vient de basculer dans
la dissidence bref il demande à laval de
montrer que il est le véritable patron
en france moment en zone sud alors ça
c'est l'arrêt des raisons internes
behind raisons externes d'un jeune
entité c'est à dire eh bien c'est la
réussite de l'opération torch la
réussite donc changé mais débarquement
donc anglo saxons en afrique du nord est
la conséquence comme vous le savez c'est
que y'a pus l'armée d'armistice il ya
plus de flotte il n'ya plus quasiment
d'empyr dont clichy se sent un peu seul
et un peu nu et c'est alors que laval
qui se défiaient darnand qui se défiait
son entourage parce qu'ils avaient
l'impression d'une pas suffisamment de
maîtrise et sautent le pas et décide
effectivement de créer par une loi en
bonne et due forme donc cette milice
française c'est la loi numéro 63 des 30
janvier 1943 l'heure de la miss est donc
ce n'est tout à fait le président la
balle a décidé que le service d'ordre
légionnaire les prendrais dorénavant du
gouvernement et serait transformé en
ministre française tout en restant sous
les ordres de monsieur joseph d'armes
le 30 janvier 1943 la milice française
est créée officiellement elle prend pour
emblème le gamma symbole de force et de
renouveau les statuts publiés au journal
officiel précisent ses missions soutenir
l'état nouveau concourir au maintien de
l'ordre 5 grandes directions s'organise
un service de la propagande est confiée
à francis couplant un deuxième services
chargés du renseignement reviennent à
joseph de gang un ancien de l'as cannes
en mai paraît combat le journal de la
milice
aux côtés des signatures dans rio de
chefs miliciens on retrouve dans les
pages culturelles celle de colette paul
morand mac orlan
[Musique]
la nouvelle organisation structurée
militairement est très hiérarchisé les
recrues prête serment au cours de
cérémonies solennelles
bon j'accepte librement les disciplines
au château de saint martin d'uriage près
de grenoble
l'école des cadres de la milice se met
en place on y assure la formation
politique des stagiaires et la formation
militaire orientée vers les combats de
guerre civile souligne un document
d'époque
pour mener ces combats darnand créée en
juin 43 la france garde composée
d'hommes jeunes décidés à en découdre
elle sera le fer de lance de la milice
le bras armé chargé des sales besognes
elles étaient 43 la milice piétine laval
se méfie de darnand et ne lui donne pas
les armes qu'ils réclament darnand doute
au poil qu'il songe à changer de camp il
prend contact avec londres qui ne
répondra pas c'est à ce moment là que
les allemands lui propose la création
d'une va faner 16 française darnand
décide alors de jouer la carte allemande
jusqu'au bout en outre 43 à l'ambassade
d'allemagne il prête serment à hitler
l'ancien combattants de 14-18
germanophobe et patriote est devenu un
ultra de la collaboration armés il va
entraîner avec lui la milice française
dès le mois d'octobre des cadres de la
ministre dont francis brûlant s'engage
également dans les waffen ss
peu après les allemands livre des
mitraillettes pour armer la france garde
[Musique]
darnand lui-même dans combat lance un
appel pour l'enrôlement des miliciens
dans la waffen ss
[Musique]
dans cette année 43 la résistance se
développent et s'attaquent de plus en
plus à la milice
[Musique]
en novembre jacquemin le chef
départemental haute savoie et un autres
miliciens sont abattus
désormais la mélisse organise la
répression par ses propres moyens sans
en référer aux autorités
ainsi le 2 décembre 43 l'assassinât de
maurice sarraut est monté par des
miliciens qui veulent empêcher un
rapprochement entre certains milieux
vichyssois et d'anciens parlementaires
radicaux à la recherche d'une
hypothétique troisième voie entre
résistance et collaboration
à la fin de 43 la pression allemande sur
vichy s'accentue encore ickler exige
l'entrée au gouvernement de
personnalités sur comme darnand est un
bourgogne et rend les armes le vainqueur
de verdun ça vous le vassal d'hitler
[Musique]
le 19 décembre tous les ultras de la
collaboration vichyssoise et parisienne
se retrouvent ensemble d'accord sur
l'essentiel la guerre totale aux côtés
de l'allemagne
impossible et héritant entre les deux où
la mort sera exsangue sur libération où
elle sera libérée des fleurs rosconi
succès dans la tribune joseph darnand
[Applaudissements]
joseph darnand le chef de la milice
émergent comme l'homme de la situation
l'homme des allemands
jean pierre azéma cette milice qui se
crée donc en janvier 1943 comment
comment ça marche qu'est ce que le
recrutement répond aux attentes des
initiateurs
le mirage avait plus de 30 mille
miliciens et darnand
attendait mieux et plus
il faut il faut bien voir que la milice
on prend à la fois ce qu'on appelle donc
des sédentaires qui sont des militants
qui viennent à la fois de l'extrême
droite et aussi d'un certain nombre de
notables
traditionalistes des vichyssois un petit
peu pur et dur voilà une catégorie et
puis très progressivement darnand a
voulu que la milice ce fut armée et de
la faune garde inquiète à ce moment là
une milice de gens beaucoup plus jeune
qui est une milice encasernés et qu'on
va utiliser donc dans les opérations
notamment contre les maquis est contre
et contre les résistants on recrute
alors souvent des des gens enfin des
gens on recrute donc beaucoup moins des
militants qu'un certain nombre
d'ouvriers agricoles sa recrutement
beaucoup plus populaires on a pu parler
d'un fascisme plaidé gains et s'ils
viennent à la milice c'est tout
simplement parce qu'ils y gagnent de
l'argent
ils ont aussi donc un équipement il
évite le st lô donc voilà vous avez une
branche politique qui est contrôlé par
les vieux de la vieille si j'ose dire
qui serait dur voilà le noyau dur et
puis vous avez une franc garde beaucoup
plus jeune mais qui commandait aussi par
les gens qui politiquement sont sûrs
alors à l'intérieur de cela vous avez un
certain nombre gros quatre bureaux et
services comme ils disent là et à ce
fameux ce fameux deuxième service là
quoi il sert et quelques mois on a vu là
qu'il a été créé mais il fait du
renseignement ça signifie quoi faire du
renseignement dans la 1843 le fameux
parce que les musiciens l'ont beaucoup
développés alors qu'il avait une triple
fonction la première c'est d'abord de
surveiller celles et ceux qui entrent
dans la milice parce qu'il ya aussi des
musiciennes sélection la sélection voilà
non tâche seconde tâche non moins
importantes
obtenir des renseignements sur
l'extérieur et en particulier sur les
ennemis sur l'anti france les trois âges
le fichage de manière systématique et
puis troisième point énonciation
j'imagine en récupérant notamment des
négociations et puis troisième point
préparer à préparer très concrètement le
terrain pour l'action c'est à dire donc
les actions menées notamment contre les
résistants ou contre les juifs chef de
ce deuxième service et deux banques est
un ancien de la de la cagoule mais il
faut noter et souligné qu' en savoie le
cher le deuxième service c'est paul
touvier dès l'année 1943 avril 43 avant
il va devenir le patron de suite de
l'ensemble de de la région autour de
lyon bon il ya une chose qui maintenant
qu'il faut expliquer bien parce que
c'est pas trés c'est difficile à
comprendre c'est l'évolution de cette
milice française vers vers la
collaboration absolue armée avec les
allemands et notamment ses d'évolution
de jodar nom joseph darnand donc sept
anciens combattants de 14-18
germanophobe et qui va s'engager dans la
ss comme une évolution totalement
surprenante de raison qu'ils jouent la
première est l'anti bolchevisme assez
fondamental à partir de juin 41 et à 7 à
10 h église se joint donc de vieux
règlement de comptes contre ce qu'il
appelle la démocratie mûrit donc contre
les démocraties libérales ce qui fait
qu'après avoir hésité c'est tout à fait
vrai darnand avec et ses très proches
vont prêter serment à partir de 1943 au
führer et vont devenir donc des waffen
ss et je voudrais citer très brièvement
un texte francis bout de l'an qui est le
second darnand au début 1944 fait cette
précision très clair dans le petit
parisien du 27 janvier il y as
distinction a fait en tant que militaire
nous faisons effectivement le serment au
führer mais joseph darnand a fait en
août son serment politique au chef de
l'état il ne faillira pas plus à celui
ci qu'à celui là les deux sont sacrés
donc les chefs de la milice
sont pris alors tout à fait dans un
engrenage et se trouve de fait même
s'ils appartiennent l'ultra-droite 10 6
was extrêmement près des thèses des
collaborationnistes
donc à ce moment là une sorte de fusion
entre les thèses collaborationniste est
ce qu'on est et la droite extrême et
finalement c'est ça qui va prendre le
pouvoir à vichy avec l'instauration
l'entrée au gouvernement de des
miliciens oui et à ce moment là on
pourra parler d'état miliciens
[Musique]
on
est complice
des police
de vichy
le 30 décembre 43 la radio annonce la
nomination de joseph darnand comme
secrétaire général au maintien de
l'ordre il a maintenant autorité sur
l'ensemble des forces de police
philippe henriot est nommé au
secrétariat d'état à la propagande et à
l'information
[Musique]
deux miliciens occupe désormais des
postes clefs dans l'appareil d'état
henriot qui parle de fois par jour à la
radio peu dans ses activités de
porte-parole officiel de l'état français
faire passer le message miliciens il
tente non sans efficacité de répondre
point par point aux arguments de la bbc
[Applaudissements]
puis les palio est allemand philipp en
nommant philippe
dépendre des compatriotes français au
lendemain d'une défaite dans laquelle
tout le monde avait perdu la terre que
vos professeurs de patriotisme est
aujourd'hui abrité derrière les micros
de londres d'alger voudrais bien savoir
vous en seriez
on nous dit qu'on ne donne pas des
patriotes nous acceptons le fait de la
défaite en avons le faire aussi batterie
est aussi déchiré que vous êtes en
attendant partir de là courageusement
pour faire les efforts nécessaires et
remonter avec des méthodes ans et sous
des chefs en fait pour assurer un
relèvement foncerai et c'est vous qui
nous dit que nous sommes pas des
papillons donc il y avait tellement
perdu la foi dans notre patrie vous le
comptait plus que jour l'étranger pour
lui rapporter
dès son entrée en fonctions darnand
cherche à placer ses hommes dans les
rouages de l'état il est pur
l'administration et se livrent une
véritable colonisation de l'appareil
administratif judiciaire et policier
noyautée par les hommes en noir un état
miliciens se met en place les cadres de
la police l'administration pénitentiaire
et les cours martiales pas sous
l'autorité de darnand
fin janvier 44 les allemands autorise
l'activité de la milice temps au nord
les troupes de darnand peuvent parader
sur les champs elysées l'arc de triomphe
a vu défiler des troupes plus glorieuses
jean-pierre h du matin la ministre a le
pouvoir à vichy en janvier 44 sous la
pression des allemands qu'est ce qu'il
reste comme pouvoirs à pétain qui
s'incline sa latitude d'action et
diminuer c'est tout à fait vrai il
demeure quand même le chef de l'état
français il faut pas l'oublier fadil
d'action a diminué parce que il a essayé
à l'automne 1943 de prendre un peu le
large de prendre un peu ses distances
vis-à-vis vis-à-vis de l'allemagne
et c'est leur ep sur les doigts il le
fait un petit peu comme
sont parvenus à le faire dans une large
mesure les italiens dans l'automne 1943
et les allemands tout à fait échaudé par
ce qui s'est passé en italie donc on dit
à son là il n'en est pas question et
donc que philippe pétain a dû accepter
que le nouveau secrétaire général au
maintien de l'ordre s'appelle
effectivement joseph darnand qui du même
coup possède une double casquette bleue
casque voilà il est à la fois toujours
de fête patron de la dce et d'autre part
il a en tant que secrétaire général au
maintien d'ordre des pouvoirs accrus et
on peut et on doit le considérer comme
un ministre de l'état français lui a
demandé si la milice investi l'état est
ce qu'on peut et est ce que c'est juste
de parler de l'état miliciens assez le
titre qu'on a donné à cette émission est
ce qu'il ya vraiment un état miliciens à
944 à vichy dans une large mesure
totalement c'est vrai mais je dirais
qu'on peut parler d'un état miliciens
parce que vichy a toujours été un régime
autoritaire et lannilis darnand les
miliciens vont contrôler trois secteurs
fondamentaux d'un régime autoritaire
d'abord la police à partir du 10 janvier
darnand devient le patron de toutes les
polices françaises tout le maintien de
l'ordre se soient responsabilisées sa
responsabilité en zone nord quand la
zone sud puisque la milice à
l'autorisation avant l'autorisation de
surcroît de se développer en zone nord
le premier point le deuxième point la
milice a aussi la responsabilité à
travers un monsieur qui s'appelle
philippe henriot de la propagande voilà
l'efficacité redoutable des discours
d'un roi il est incertain miliciens de
2,2 puis enfin il il est passé à la
milice il est sur des positions
collaborationniste parce que depuis 1941
donc lurçat a été envahi par par le
reich donc par le combat anti veulent
chérif donc c'est un il parle quand deux
fois deux fois par jour donc sa deuxième
secteur troisième secteur la milice
contrôler les la plupart des grandes
centrales
pénitentiaire et contrôlent les grandes
directions dont pénitentiaire c'est à
dire qu'ils vont contrôler et donc à la
fois la police le les médias et d'autre
part donc eu une bonne partie de la
justice d'autant plus que des cours
martiales qui vont maintenant être se
tenir notamment contre les résistants la
plupart des juges de ces commerciales
sont de fait des miliciens et on voit un
peu partout dans l'administration
française
des miliciens qui sont nommés comme
attendant de police attendant du
maintien de l'ordre à des prêts faits
miliciens bref si
l'état français n'est pas totalement
faux cité
mini siens et bien être une finalité est
ce que le recrutement à la base de la
milice en 44 change il change
partiellement parce que une partie
de ce que j'ai appelé tout à l'heure les
notables traditionalistes ont quitté à
nice
lorsqu'ils ont appris que
joseph darnand et donc et ses amis ont
prêté serment au führer alors phénomène
un petit peu de compensation en voilà
une nouvelle recrue sont beaucoup plus
de types comme je disais dans la frange
gamme de type plutôt au fascisme
plébéien on va donc chercher donc des
gens beaucoup plus jeunes beaucoup moins
politisés également mais qui seront
alors le fer de lance armée contre la
résistance justement va voir maintenant
dans le sujet qui celui-là la milice
dans les combats contre la résistance et
contre les maquis
[Musique]
au début de 1944 se confondant avec
l'état qu'elle a investi
la milice fait régner un climat de
terreur en toute impunité
[Musique]
couverts par leur chef les miliciens
contrôle surveille kadri traque s chine
exécute
le 10 janvier 1944 le président de la
ligue des droits de l'homme dit orban 80
ans et sa femme sont assassinés à lyon
exécuté de la main même du chef régional
de la milice joseph lécussan
[Musique]
en savoie en apportant ma qui se forment
les résistants rendent coup pour coup
aux exactions des forces de l'ordre
[Musique]
sur ce document rare un jeune maquisard
indique l'emplacement où des miliciens
exécutés ont été enterrés
[Musique]
chaque enterrement de miliciens darnand
est présent comme ici à vichy
[Musique]
ces images exceptionnelles tourné par et
mon père il ya un résistant de l'armée
secrète montra parachutage sur le
plateau des glières où se sont regroupés
au début de 44 les principaux maquis de
haute savoie les résistants veulent
créer un abcès de fixation
situation intolérable pour ficher
[Musique]
le 13 février le plateau est bouclée par
un millier de miliciens venus de toute
la france et par autant de gendarmes
les forces de vichy sont tenus en échec
par les 450 maquisards
[Musique]
les allemands arrivent en renfort ils
bombardent le plateau et donne l'assaut
[Musique]
on
les maquisards se replie et se disperse
les miliciens est capable de l'emporter
sur le terrain se surpasse dans le
ratissage et l'interrogatoire des
prisonniers
les freins garde qui ont participé au
nettoyage du plateau des glières arrive
pas difficile sont salués par leur chef
monsieur goût de l'art mais hélas
plusieurs de leurs camarades ne sont
plus des soldats de l'ordre ont donné
leur vie pour défendre le pays contre le
crime et le banditisme
[Musique]
après le débarquement de normandie
la milice prend part activement aux
combats contre le maquis le 7 juin darna
remobilise ses hommes par un appel radio
diffusée
les ordres sont claires
considérés comme des ennemis de la
france les francs tireurs et partisans
les membres de la prétendue armée
secrète
attaquez vous aux saboteurs traquer les
traîtres fait leur fasse comme dans le
limousin
dans les alpes en bretagne dans le
limousin la france garde se montre
particulièrement implacable envers les
résistants les miliciens mène la guerre
civile aux côtés de l'occupant les
exactions commises par les hommes de
darnand au printemps et à l'été 44 sont
épouvantables ils pillent violent
assassine
jean zay et georges mandel figurent
parmi leurs victimes
[Musique]
guillaume dans sa grille et la nuit et a
gâché les allemands
[Musique]
le 28 juin 1944 la résistance exécute
philippe henriot le porte-voix de l'état
miliciens lors de ses obsèques
nationales les officiels allemands sont
au côté de laval tout un symbole
et
je e
il jean pierre azéma finalement en 1944
la milice était à la fois auxiliaires
des allemands et instruments de la
guerre civile franco française pour ac2
logique tout à fait il ya vous avez tout
à fait raison il ya une double logique
gagne logique donc franco française
des guerres civiles et il y à une
logique franco-allemand
logique franco-française jeu ont une
historienne dira que le vichy 1940
quatre étaient forcément inscrits dans
le vichy de 1940 mais les historiens
jouteront immédiatement qu'il n'ya rien
à d'incohérent dans cette trajectoire et
qu' il y à une certaine logique la
montée en puissance
d'une ultra droite
vichyssoise qui existait depuis l'été
parce que aussi vichy a pratiqué dès
l'été 40
l'exclusion la répression parce que
également
vichy est un régime obsédé par l'ordre
est ce qui vous explique philippe pétain
encore le 5 juin 1944
va donner quitus à saint-lys je le cite
je suis heureux de savoir que grâce à la
milice j'ai des troupes fidèles un peu
partout en france quand une fois ça se
passe ça se sait que jean labé du
débarquement avec un débarquement est ce
que est ce que ses troupes sont les
fidèles sont efficaces dans leur combat
contre compter maquis contre la
résistance oui alors là on arrive dans
une autre logique c'est la logique la
logique franco-allemande c'est à dire
que il ya un glissement progressif alors
dans les rapports franco allemand est
que ceux qui contrôlent de fait le
pouvoir sont ceux qui maintenant
militent ouvertement donc pour une
france intégré ou d'une manière ou d'une
autre donc à l'europe
à l'europe fasciste encore donné de
multiples exemples il faut savoir par
exemple que le délégué de la milice en
zone nord qui vint donc des proches de
darnand rencontre le chef des ss en
france qui s'appelle hohberg monf la
barre semaine hinault ses ordres oui
dans une très large mesure deux autres
illustrations des miliciens vont devenir
des rabatteurs pour
pour les forces allemandes
c'est flagrant
lorsque l'opération est monté de contre
le maquis des glières donc entre février
et mars 1944 voilà c'est les miliciens
et les gmr qui boucle c'est les
allemands qui attaque c'est aussi un
milicien qui ensuite se prennent dans la
nasse les résistants qui ont pu échapper
c'est aussi à ce moment là les miliciens
qui interroge et de quelle manière
c'est aussi les miliciens qui vont être
utilisés à partir du 8 juin 1944 lorsque
darna va l'immobiliser et que des
affronts card avec un certain nombre de
chefs comme les apps et miliciens ont
lettre on peut le dire à feu et à sang
le parti de la france en rage au radon
bretagne ce serait épouvantable dans le
limousin
également par exemple à
saint-amand-montrond où ils
participeront à
l'extermination enfin oui à la vie à
l'extermination volontaire donc de juifs
de
de cette petite cité et ce qu'on sait
comment l'opinion les français à
l'époque voyez la milice oui on sait on
le sait par les rapports des préfets
parce que les rapports des préfets
n'était pas favorable aux miliciens
parce que la milice allez un petit peu
sur la brise et nous laisse également
par la synthèse du contrôle postale où
il est évident que la milice est presque
unanimement détesté en france et d'arles
on le sait qu il le dit d'ailleurs c'est
une toute petite minorité qui s'ouvre à
des français avachi etc
la milice était détesté pour moins deux
raisons 1 parce qu'il était devenu
ouvertement les auxiliaire de l'occupant
j'ai dit et puis également parce que
dans cette guerre franco-française
c'était des tortionnaires ils ont enduré
près d'ici dans un château à quelques
kilomètres de vichy et châteaux des
brosses ils ont torturé à la caserne
lors à montpellier ils sont torturés à
lyon ils sont torturés par tous donc
cette réputation à la fois d'être des
traîtres comme auxiliaire de l'occupant
y compris après le débarquement et de
tortionnaires de français va leur coûter
très très cher
nous avons attendu six ans le monde
nous comptons plus beaucoup de temps
bleuté près de lui quand disparu et
comme vous mais cannes arables de leur
dette rien le garde maintenant pierre un
nouveau destin continue de notre patrie
je suis à votre tête
désormais près de vous parmi vous ont
fait valoir multi j'en suis qui nous
conduira à la victoire
qu'est ce qui se passe justement à la
libération de télé le destin des décès
miliciens des miliciens en principe pris
les armes à la main a été fusillé je dis
bien pris les armes à la main donc ce
chiffre et le nom de miliciens qui ont
été exécutés ou abattus dans l'est dans
les combats ou juste après les combats
de libération peut-être 15 cents à 2000
peut-être
r ce qui arriva à fuyons voyons tout
vielles notre parc des jours ci niché en
france mais aussi en allemagne ça c'est
le 3e 3e - c'est ça qui fut en allemagne
vont devenir
commerciaux nerfs parce que les
allemands ont déroulé dans fonds et
darnand lui même c'est à dire qu'on va
pas leur laisser le choix où l'on
travaille en usine les femmes et les
enfants seront dans des camps dans des
conditions qui ne sont pas très
agréables et les autres n'auront pas le
choix devront s'engager dans la division
charlemagne qui se fera et trier donc on
personnalise donc par les forces
politiques les principaux chefs
s'échapperont pour partie d'entre eux
notamment en italie ils seront priés à
cela ils seront jugés
leur chef donc darnand passera devant
une autre cour de justice puisqu'il
était secrétaire général au maintien de
l'ordre
son procès de manière tout à fait
significatives et de rats moins d'un
jour donc et il sera immédiatement
exécuté en octobre 1945
comment expliquez-vous que un demi
siècle après finalement on prend le voit
avec parce qu'on vient de dire mais la
milice ça reste synonyme videmment de
d'horreur de série b devant faire de
trous noirs et dont on parle encore
comme avec répulsion il n'y a pas de
révisionnistes
non il n'y a pas de véritable historien
révisionniste cela me lis j'entends par
là qui essaye de démontrer que dans le
fond la milice répondait des objectifs
de compliqué je voudrais terminer si
vous voulez pour expliquer cela
simplement sur une citation cette
citation c'est un télégramme quand voit
donc le second de d'arnaud clipping à
francis boulle ans qui était responsable
de la milice à vichy en juillet 1944
après que les miliciens ont été
assassinés georges mandel avec la
complicité des allemands et voilà
comment ça se termine mon opinion est
que tout en étant le boyau gouvernement
il faut que nous représentions
d'éléments révolutionnaire qui les
pousse à faire ce qu'il ne fait pas par
tempérament et qui depuis trois ans nous
a conduits dans la pince outre on stoppe
ne pas agir dans la sphère d'hier dont
l'exécution de georges mandel
l'ex-ministre de l'intérieur dont
quétier qui est donc exécuté à la fois
comme baby si c'est comme juif ne pas
agir dans la sphère d'hier aurait eu
pour conséquence de nous faire perdre
entièrement la confiance d espèce c'est
ainsi que se termine ce télégramme je
crois qu'il n'y a rien à ajouter tout
est dit et qu'on comprend que c'est
vraiment à des moments les plus noirs de
cette histoire noire des années sombres
pour terminer cette émission il ya très
peu de livres il faut le dire il ya ceux
là dont vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
l'histoire de la milice tel perry de
beac qui datent de 69 beaucoup de choses
dedans mais qui est très riche et qui je
prend malheureusement épuisé très
difficile à trouver tout à fait pour
être dans l'actualité de ces jours-ci de
livres le un certain monsieur paul la
sphère touvier de leurs engrais lammer
et daniel schneidermann qui raconte
l'histoire de touvier paru chez fayard
qui reparaît ces jours ci dans une
nouvelle édition et puis le rapport paul
touvier et l'église
la commission d'historiens à laquelle
vous avez participé sous la
responsabilité de rené rémond paru
également chez fayard voilà cette
émission est terminée et la semaine
prochaine